today represents a very significant
moment of change
it's a defining moment for our politics
and for our people
today ushers in a new era which i
believe presents us all with an
opportunity to reimagine relationships
in this society on the basis of fairness
on the basis of equality and on the
basis of social justice
irrespective of religious political or
social backgrounds
my commitment is to make politics work
my commitment is to work through
partnership not division
we will work with those who serve and
all other political perspectives we will
work together we will show respect and
we expect to be shown respect
there is a space in this place for
everyone all of us together
i will provide leadership which is
inclusive which celebrates diversity
which guarantees rights and equality for
those who have been excluded
discriminated against or ignored in the
past
we all heard loud and clear on the doors
throughout this campaign
people demand cooperation people demand
delivery they demand that we address the
cost of living crisis that we invest in
our health service
and the welfare of people all people
comes first
and that's the reason why on monday we
must all turn up together that's the
reason why on monday there is an urgency
to restore an executive to start to put
money back in people's pockets to start
to fix the health service the people
can't wait
we will turn up i will lead my team up
to dormant on monday
the people have told us throughout the
course of this election that they expect
us to work together
the people are right guard military